كنت اكتب المعلومات اللي كنت اسمعها
الاشخاص اللي كنت اشوفهم اللي اسمع
اسمائهم المخططات داعش كنت اكتب كلها عندي
[موسيقى]
فتره اللي كنت عند السيره عند ابو محمد
العدناني كنت اشوفه كثير يدربون اشخاص
بعدين يطلعوهم على دول دول العربيه
يطلعوهم على اي دوله
يعتبروهم هذه الخلايا اذا
متواضع الدوله هم اللي راح يساعدوهم ومن
ناحيه الثانيه هم كدول العناصر اللي كانوا
يصيرون خلايا خارج سوريا والعراق كانوا
يدعموهم ماديا
[موسيقى]
البدايه كانت تكسير صعبه بالنسبه لي بعدين
انا منحني قلت انه لازم انا انه خلاص اطيع
الاوامر لحتى افتح طريق لنفسي حتى يوم من
الايام هم يثقون به اقدر اهرب فما كان
بايدي شيء غير اني اطيح اوامرك كل شي كان
يطلب مني كنت اطيح اوامرك
[موسيقى]
اغلب الوقت انا قضيت مع الاولاد لان ابو
بكر البغدادي وزوجته ام خالد
فكثير كانوا مشغولين
المكتب ابو بكر البغدادي ما كان يفصل وهي
زوجته اللي هي زوجه الوحيده اللي كان يثق
فيها ومثل نقول انه ايده اليمين
هي اللي كانت تشتغل عنه كثير اشياء في
اجتماع هي تدخل معه او في كثير اشياء انه
هو ما يكون موجود هي تتحمل المسؤوليه
[موسيقى]
عصبي كثير وبلشت تضربني
وتصيح وتقول كلام انه نحن وبثقنا فيك
واعتبرناك مثل بنتنا وطلعتي انه كاتبه كل
شيء عننا
ابو بكر البغدادي طلع على الصوت على
الغرفه اللي كنت انام فيها
ولما شاف هو كمان كمل الضرب علي
وبنفس اللحظه حاول بوجود زوجتها
وجود زوجته حوالي يعتدي عليه
[موسيقى]